На Заході з острахом очікували одного, а Володимир Путін - як це нерідко бувало раніше - зробив зовсім інше.
Він не оголосив ані про перемогу в Україні, ані про загальну мобілізацію.
Не зробив також гучних заяв і про ядерну зброю.
Таку стриманість експерти пояснюють реаліями на полі бою, які виявилися зовсім іншими, ніж очікували у Кремлі.
Насамперед треба зафіксувати той факт, що перша фаза операції була для Путіна розчаруванням.
Швидкої перемоги не вийшло. А наратив про те, що Україна не має національної ідентичності
і що українці не будуть оборонятися великими силами і з високим бойовим духом, зазнав краху.
Безліч помилок, яких припустилися російські військові, стали результатом цього наративу.
І я думаю, що промова, яку Путін виголосив у День перемоги, по суті,
є визнанням того, що війна затягнеться на довше,
оскільки вона не призвела до швидкого військового успіху, на який він явно очікував.
На думку експертів, чим довше триватиме війна, тим сильнішою ставатиме українська армія
і тим більше Путін заганятиме себе у глухий кут.
Почнімо з того, що у Росії починає вичерпуватися людський ресурс.
Ми довгий час бачили, що вони намагалися нашкребти тренованих військових з останніх резервів.
Тож усе що їм залишається нині, так це призовники, які наполовину пройшли тренування,
бо були призвані у лютому…
Тож що ми бачимо, так це депрофесіоналізація армії чи принаймні зменшення професійності
російських збройних сил у той час, як війна триває.
Вони зайшли в глухий кут. З іншого боку ЗСУ в цілому стають професійнішими,
краще озброєними, більш структурованими і досвідченими.
Тож у довгостроковій перспективі, я припускаю, з огляду на це
обставини складаються вигідніше для України.
Деякі експерти вважають, що Путін нині зайняв вичікувальну позицію.
І не виключають, що згодом він ще може оголосити загальну мобілізацію резервістів.
Схоже, до нього почало доходити, що війна йде важко, і що в результаті люди гинуть або зазнають поранень.
Але він не робить з цього жодних висновків для себе.
У мене таке відчуття, що він вичікує.
Всі ці очікування щодо його можливих заяв, які передбачалися на 9 травня,
виходили не від Кремля чи прокремлівських ЗМІ.
Це були міркування у певних колах на Заході і від критиків Кремля.
Тому він не повинен був оголошувати загальну мобілізацію, але він ще може це зробити.
Щодо подальшої воєнної стратегії Росії експерти вважають, що після того,
як досягнення військових цілей першої фази війни провалилося,
РФ тепер зосередиться на завоюванні Донбасу.
У промові Путіна до  дня перемоги, яка насправді не була особливою,
а виявилася радше "вологою петардою", ми почули, що Донбас було згадано п'ять разів,
а Крим - один раз. Україну ж, до речі, наскільки я пам'ятаю, не було згадано жодного разу.
Тож ми бачимо, що фокус спрямовано на Донбас як ціль.
Припускаю, що цілі залишаються історичними, тобто південна частина України,
яку росіяни називали "Новоросією".
Я припускаю, що українське узбережжя теж є однією з основних цілей.
Вони не відмовляться від нього без бою, скажімо так.
Західні експерти кажуть, що незважаючи на широку підтримку росіянами військової операції, згідно із соцопитуваннями,
у Кремлі, нібито, побоюються, що ця підтримка може піти на спад,
якщо бойові дії почнуть відбиватися на якості життя аполітичного середнього класу.
Стало більш-менш очевидно, що російське керівництво має намір продовжувати війну аж до настання моменту,
який можна було б описати як "успіх".
Хоча я сам не завжди розумію, якою саме може бути перемога,
але загалом вона неможлива, бо в армії не вистачає кваліфікованих кадрів.
Тому що серед офіцерського складу дуже багато бойових втрат.
Як розвиватимуться бойові дії далі?
На думку експертів, Україна готує собі нині передумови для того, щоб перейти у контрнаступ.
Поза сумнівом, Україна зараз має перевагу.
Днями українська армія зайняла території дуже близько до російського кордону біля Харкова.
Іншими словами Україна вже контратакує.
Це має подвійне значення.
Перш за все, вони вже в межах артилерійської досяжності маршрутів постачання російської залізниці на південь, на Донбас.
А це велика проблема для російської логістики, бо іншого шляху в них поки немає.
По-друге, зараз їм потрібно перенаправити сили з Донбасу з уже загальмованої операції.
Українці, безперечно, готуються до великої контратаки.
І це, швидше за все, відбудеться не в травні, я б сказав, а можливо, ближче до липня.
А у росіян в певний момент їхній нинішній наступ закінчиться, кульмінує, як сказали б військові, вони видихнуться.
У цей момент українці будуть готові до контратаки, а потім вони будуть готові відвоювати території, особливо на півдні.
І це те, що ми дійсно ще побачимо - деякі важкі бої до кінця року. Так, це буде довга війна.
Тим часом Захід, судячи з усього, дедалі більше робить ставку на перемогу України.
Зокрема Конгрес США схвалив 40-мільярдний пакет допомоги Києву,
з якого 6 мільярдів доларів мають піти на закупівлю бронемашин та систем ППО для України.
Перед голосуванням спікерка Палати представників Ненсі Пелосі заявила,
що цим пакетом допомоги США посилають всьому світу сигнал про непохитну рішучість
підтримувати хоробрий народ України, поки він не переможе Москву.